the ballot of song birds and snakes is a
prequel novel that was published in 2020
it takes place 64 years before the
events of the original trilogy during
the 10th Hunger Games the games are not
yet the spectacle they will become
instead they're a militant punishment a
straightforward fight to the death
between malnourished teenagers it also
tells the story of Cory elanus snow a
young man who will later become the
ruthless president and Main antagonist
of The Hunger Games trilogy also the
name Tigress should sound familiar in
the Hunger Games books and movies
Tigress is a capital resident who
provides catniss and the other rebel
refuge in her first shop in the prequel
we get a glimpse of tigress's and Snow's
childhoods and quickly learn of their
relationship you might also remember
that Finnick in the book and on screen
revealed that President Snow used roses
to cover the scent of blood in his mouth
song birds and snakes gives a backstory
on Snow's connection to those Roses in
the mocking jay part one katus sings the
old haunting song about lovers meeting
at the Hanging Tree just keep this in
mind along with the fact that the song
was written long before Katniss was even
born